let's talk about impeachment a little
bit but not actually about impeachment
we're gonna take a break from an
impeachment talk in earnest today but I
want to talk about a sort of corollary
or tangential issue which is that Donald
Trump is now threatening to use the
Supreme Court to block possible
impeachment now before I even tell you
what's going on and the sort of legal
underpinnings of this there's a bigger
picture that I need to paint for you I
would be doing you a disservice today if
I didn't bring this up if you're the
president and you're talking this
frequently about your own impeachment
something is very very wrong it's not
normal for presidents to have to argue
against their own impeachment this much
Trump previously said people are talking
about impeachment how do you impeach a
president who's doing so well now he's
saying if impeachment was attempted I
would go to the Supreme Court to prevent
my impeachment now I understand Trump
thinking that he's thinking I have
manipulated the Supreme Court
thanks to Mitch McConnell partially
before he was president blocking Merrick
Garland's nomination he has selected
three people to the Supreme Court he
believes maybe rightly that he has the
Supreme Court in his pocket but
unfortunately this doesn't really work
but let's think it through reminder in
terms of the context growing movement
for impeachment had a clip yesterday
that got 200,000 views overnight about
this issue prominent Democrats saying
it's time for impeachment prominent
legal scholars but we're not going to
dig into that piece today Trump tweets
the Muller report despite being written
by angry Democrats and Trump haters and
with unlimited money behind it 35
million of course it's so stupid the
cost of an investigation is not to
suggest that people are throwing money
at it is very disingenuous didn't lay a
glove on me well did you read it because
it says substantial evidence of
obstruction Trump goes on to say I did
nothing wrong if the partisan Dems ever
tried to impeach I would first head to
the US Supreme Court the analysis here
is really simple impeachment and removal
of the president works like this the
House of Representatives files articles
of impeachment and sort of works as the
prosecutor the Senate then votes almost
like they are the jury and ultimately
decides whether or not to remove the
president from power there's nothing in
there that includes the possibility of
going to the Supreme Court period the
power of the House and Senate to bring
and investigate and adjudicate
impeachment is their sole power the
house brings charges the Senate is like
the jury period there's no mechanism to
appeal to the Supreme Court the Supreme
Court decides whether or not to hear
previously decided cases which have
requested appeal impeachment is a
congressional process this isn't an
argument I'm making for or against
impeachment it's just another one of
these examples of Trump doesn't get it
and it's really important to understand
this
Trump claiming that he will try to use
the Supreme Court to block impeachment
fits two common themes of the Trump
presidency
theme number one Trump doesn't actually
understand how the Constitution or
checks and balances or government work
okay that's theme number one which is
fomented confirmed by Trump saying he
would try to use the Supreme Court to
block impeachment number two it's
Trump's autocratic authoritarian
tendencies thinking that the Supreme
Court has anything to do with
impeachment and that Trump could go to
the Supreme Court and say hey stop the
impeachment from happening that shows
like with much other material that we
have that Trump has a fundamental lack
of understanding of how any of this
stuff works confirmed once again but of
course the idea that Trump could go to
the Supreme Court which is now made up
one-third of by people made made up to
33 percent of people who Trump
hand-picked making it one of the most
conservative Supreme Court's in a long
time
the idea that he thinks he could go to
them to get him out of being impeached
is that authoritarian autocratic
tendency that we've observed been
observing in Trump since day one of the
presidency he's sort of like his base in
that sense
ignorant of the law ignorant of history
ignorant of how government works but
really confident that he's correct and
that he's smart and that he's
knowledgeable and that he's the right
person to be making decisions for our
country and it's completely embodied in
his idea that if anybody tries to
impeach him anybody beating Democrats in
the House and Senate that he will go to
the Supreme Court in order to prevent
that from happening will it ever get to
that point I don't know but we will
leave it there on impeachment for today
and maybe follow up on it tomorrow
because there actually is more
impeachment news but sort of feel we've
been talking about it enough lately make
sure you're following the david pakman
show on instagram at david pakman show
make sure you're following me on
instagram at david pakman it's something
this week I believe it's the picture of
me at that Passover Seder on Saturday
every time I look at Instagram on my
phone I have 50 new followers and 10 new
comments on my picture of me at a
Passover Seder if it's as if it's a big
deal I don't really know why people are
so up in arms about it but they are and
you can see the infamous picture with me
holding a glass of wine not Manischewitz
I will mention nice wine and wearing a
bright blue yarmulke on my Instagram
page at David Pakman let me take a quick
break and we'll be back right after this
support those who support the David
Pakman show and today that includes our
good friends over at BRD Bitcoin wallet
these guys are awesome and the BRD
Bitcoin wallet is absolutely perfect for
anybody who's getting into Bitcoin or
cryptocurrency for the first time
because it was designed with simplicity
and ease of use in mind but you'll also
love it if you have experience with
Bitcoin it's an all-in-one app for iOS
and Android that lets you buy Bitcoin
and other cryptocurrencies using your
credit card lets you store everything on
the app for free you can trade and sell
cryptocurrency within the app and when
you use BRD wallet you're the only
person who has access to your Bitcoin
BRD doesn't store any of your personal
information
you don't even have nor do you need a
username and password on the platform
it's all within an environment that's
virtually impossible to hack so your
cryptocurrency is safe extremely easy to
use
it's how I store my own Bitcoin I think
you'll be impressed with it too it's the
first ever Bitcoin wallet in the iOS App
Store and now they have over two million
users for more than 170 countries BR DS
mission is to make buying selling and
storing Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies simpler more efficient
and more secure and they've done an
awesome job check out my interview with
Aaron from the BRD team we had a really
interesting discussion about the state
of cryptocurrency going forward you can
also download the BRD app for ios and
android i've put a link right underneath
this video